تقع القرية بين جبال الألب الفرنسية
وتشتهر بأنها واحدة من أفضل وجهات التزلج في العالم ،
ولكن الآن في نسختها السادسة هنا
تستمر بطولة الجولف في
النمو ،
وقد دُعيت للمشاركة في هذا
الحدث لمعرفة مدى اختلافها
يلعب على
البيض بدلاً من الخضر الذين ينضمون إلي
في البطولة أمثال
كابتن كأس ريدر الأوروبية توماس بيورن
والفائز بجولات أوروبية أربع مرات رافائيل
جاكلين. أتذكر لعب الجولف عندما كنت طفلاً
وأحيانًا في الدنمارك سيكون هناك
القليل  من
الثلج وسنظل نغامر بالخروج ولعب
التزلج كان في الواقع جزءًا كبيرًا من
حياتي الأصغر سنًا ، اعتدت الذهاب
كثيرًا وعندما أتيت إلى أي جبال الألب
وكان الطقس رائعًا ، لم يكن
أفضل بكثير
مما تعرفه  ربما تكون عطلة رائعة في لعبة الجولف
مساوية لها
ولكنك تعلم أنها شيء رائع.أحبها
،
أحبها على جانب الجبل ولكن
أيضًا أدرك جيدًا أنني
متزلج معاق 36
نحاول مزج التزلج والجولف
لإظهار الأشخاص الذين يسألوننا
أننا نستطيع أن نلعب الجولف وكذلك على الثلج ،
فالأمر مختلف كما ترون
أنه ليس سهلاً ، إنه صعب ولكن نعم إنه
رائع
[موسيقى]
لذا فهذه لعبة غولف شتوية مستقرة
لأنها أربع كرات  من الأفضل
أن تحافظ على الكرة في المسار الصحيح
إذا دخلت في منطقة قاسية ثقيلة
كما هو الحال في الانجرافات الثلجية ، أخشى أن
تكون هذه ركلة جزاء وأن الخضر
مصنوعة حرفيًا من الجليد ،
لذا هذا هو الخشونة التي كنت عليها
نتحدث عن كل هذا المسحوق
إذا دفنت كرتك في هذا ، فأنت تعلم أنه
يجب عليك تسديد ركلة جزاء أو يجب عليك
رفعها خارجها
لكنني رأيت كرتى تستقر ، لذا
سأحاول فعلاً تشغيلها
[موسيقى]
إنها متعة جيدة ، إنها ليست لعبة غولف كما
نعرفها ، لكنها
نوع من أنواع الجولف
التي لا تزال تجذب الناس للعب
اللعبة بطريقة مختلفة